yeah absolutely
and it's it's funny too because i
whenever friends are like i want to
start a youtube channel i'm like do it
just do it
start doing it with your iphone start
this i do the same say the same thing
just do it just and they're like yeah
but i wanted to be good i'm like don't
you understand [ __ ] that this is what
you didn't tell me
do it and do it as bad as as good as you
can
even though it's probably going to be
pretty bad because it really doesn't
matter because
nobody's watching right nobody's
watching it so don't worry about it you
got three subscribers and those are two
of them live in your house
yeah yeah at least at least make a
couple bucks while you practice right
right just
just yeah just put them out there
because it starts the process of getting
the subscribers and getting the watch
hours
so starting crappy and then guess what
leave them up
because two years from now or four years
from now when your channel's doing great
and it's making money
you can look back on the very first
videos you put out and go oh my god that
was terrible
how bad this one was and you'll laugh
about it it's better to have it out
there
yeah i'm so embarrassed of our first
podcast they're so [ __ ] awful
so are they still up i'm still dumb as
hell but i was so much dumber two years
ago
it's incredible how dumb i am i i'm
gonna
jump in and and it's not that incredible
at the moment the moment i disagree with
you it amazes me how dumb i am
but yeah it's so true i want to stop you
um yeah yeah what's uh so
how what do you mean on your first ones
like you've had you've been doing this
for years three years right
almost three years i think it's about
it'll be three years i think uh this
like august who's the first uh person
ben
ben the first the first the first two
the first two or three the first like
four podcasts were all with ben
and we started having guests with ben
and then is that the one that was like
in your kitchen or something no you
wanna hear something crazy
ben had he bought this [ __ ] mansion
in uh
downtown clearwater that used to be
owned by some [ __ ] millionaire
scientologist
and the basement was an auditing room so
you know where they do you know what
auditing is in scientology right
oh oh auto okay yeah yeah definitely i
know what that is so i thought you meant
audit
i thought you meant they were cpas no no
no no no no they have the scene no it's
where
they hook you up to the electronic
machine and then you tell all your
[ __ ] deepest secrets or whatever
right so it was basically like a
sound sound studio it was all sound
proof
and everything it's already pretty
simple pretty much already a studio and
before
before it was owned by the scientologist
it was owned by
somebody that was related to presley's
like one of the presley's daughters
lisa marie presley used to live over
there so it was her old house so she
used to have a recording studio
downstairs
and then after that it was an auditing
room and then after that when ben moved
in we turned it into a podcast room
so that was the first studio so the
first episode of the concrete podcast
we're in a [ __ ] scientology
auditing room and you had a you had a
screen up
right no we just we were just in a tiny
little room with a plastic table
okay the one you were thinking when
we're in the other room at this building
oh okay yeah i liked that setup yeah
yeah did we ever have you in there no
no no but i had watched it and i was
like like i've been watching different
ones and i was like this is a good
setup here oh and it has a ford right
like i'd watch like
you know like um tommy my buddy tommy
with uh
mscs media that's like okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the indian guy right the indian toys
italian yeah
when you say that which is hilarious so
i say it all the time
um i was like danny was asking about the
indian guy he said wait with the indian
guy he's like
he gets all don't don't don't tell him i
said that he's gonna i don't want him
don't whack me
don't tell him not to whack me i don't
want to get whacked he um
he his is a total joe rogan rip
off like i mean he's got the joe rogan
mike this is all joe roger this is a joe
rogan but he's got the i mean
the angle it is identical to joe rogan's
like it's horrible bro he's got the big
wire it's it's horrible like oh the big
mike's the big mike
everything everything that he even got
the camera and i'm like
why don't you just set it the way you
like it well i like the way rogan does
it i'm like
bro you're just what are you doing
you're not rogan you're not rogan like
do your own thing it's all kind of the
same but you know it's
you know i've been i'm telling them like
lower the camera angles why are your
cameras with
yeah but that's how rogan had if you
look at the first what are you doing
yeah
like a lot of people there there's no
more original ideas matt there's nothing
there's no more
original ideas it's true it's sad but
true
it's just it's all about how good you
are at hiding your sources
and he's not very good at hiding his
sources no no no oh i've listened i've
messed with him on when he's on camera
i've yelled that bill what are you doing
he's like i like joe rogan
you know he's not lying about it he's
like what
yeah it is pretty identical right yeah
it is it is
so is this though i mean all podcasts
are [ __ ] from joe rogan he's the one
who started it that's what everyone's
trying to do everyone's trying to be as
successful as he is right
and that's why i want to do this serial
for the true crime thing yeah
super different i love those podcasts
too yeah it's just so much work to make
them you know i mean
right that's why so much i spent making
a documentary it's an audio documentary
it really is that's why i was saying
with you like that's how i want to do it
and i can't do it on my own i don't have
the time the equipment that
you're like just sit down with a mic and
start doing it and the problem with
with those is they're really good but
you can't put out a lot of them so if
you're making if you're if your platform
is youtube then it's not going to be
successful
it's not going to be as successful
because youtube is all about putting out
stuff
every week every day it's 12 a season
right that's what we're negotiating for
12 of them
as long as you can do that are you
saying are you going to do that
alongside your normal podcast on your on
youtube
yeah that's what are they going to say
shut down youtube no that's a part of
the well i can we can't cover the same
material
which is fine i been covered in my
materials so you can't even promote it
on your podcast
like hey there's a new episode coming
out on the third oh no
they just want me to this is what it's
about no they want me they would want me
to do that what i can't do is i can't
say
i can't talk about let's say the the
chip the thing i'm researching right now
the the chip robberies
it's called the company it's the these
guys from the um
uh try these chinese triad members that
start robbing
computer chip manufacturers happened
back in the late 80s early 90s
so i can't cover that story on my
personal podcast
i'm sorry i can't cover it on their
podcast like
what if we do four episodes and break it
down we do interviews and everything
and then while that happens i turn
around and go on my podcast and go
and then start talking about the exact
same thing then it's like what and i
totally get that that's not that's
perfectly complicated right
even if it's just having like telling
the story over the course of two hours
they're like
you know because when you do it on a
podcast like that you're basically
creating
intellectual property right which can
then be packaged so you've got to be
able to
have a conversation about a touch on the
cliff no obviously
minor but i can't if it takes if it's
six hours to do
or it's four hours of of for you know an
hour each episode for four episodes
i can't then sit down and tell this
whole story in two hours on my own
yeah like if we talked about before oh
yeah it's about these guys if we had a
five minute conversation or ten minute
conversation okay
yeah right but so i get so i get and i
get that that makes sense i mean they
want me to do podcasts they're saying no
we want you to podcast we want you to
promote this and do all this and keep
doing what you're doing because
they're like you're becoming you're
slowly becoming
the kind of go-to guy for true crime
and for you know being you know cons and
frauds and all that stuff
you